something really strange is happening at
white house press briefings
lately it's almost like reporters don't
have any idea what to ask about
and i don't want to suggest that there
is nothing to ask about
as i've talked about for weeks now joe
biden's failed executive order on
stopping deportations
foreign policy questions minimum wage
there are plenty of things to ask about
during gensake's white house press
briefings
but for some reason reporters at press
briefings
are increasingly concerned with asking
over and over and over again why won't
you call the situation at the border
a crisis which is just this endlessly
semantic
question and yesterday questions about
joe biden's dogs and possibly a cat
i'm not joking joe biden's younger dog
major biden bit someone at the white
house the person
is fine uh as of yesterday it wasn't
totally clear who it was
as of today it seems that it was a
secret service agent it was reported
that major biden
was sort of surprised as a secret
service agent came around the corner
something like that had a minor injury
treated at the white house
now after one reporter had already asked
about it yesterday
another reporter asks a follow-up and
the question is phrased
in a wacky histrionic dramatic way
asking whether gen saki can assure the
american public
that major biden isn't going to be
euthanized look at this
about three things that's okay the dogs
immigration and then governor
another dog's question okay go ahead
just a quick clarification on the dogs
okay um can you confirm that it was a
secret service member who was bitten
and can you also reassure the public
that major biden will not be euthanized
as a result of this
well certainly major biden is a member
of the family so i can assure you that
i don't have any more details on the
individual i would encourage you to ask
the secret service but i'm not going to
have any more
details other than that it's all phrased
in
the most histrionic and dramatic terms
possible
jen can you assure the public as if the
public is waiting around to know this
that major won't be euthanized if you
have to ask
a second question about joe biden's dogs
maybe it would be
has the biden family determined how they
will handle major biden in the future
in light of this dog bite like if you if
you are going to insist on asking more
about it
but can you reassure us he won't be
euthanized
just desperate to create controversy
if she had said i have no idea whether
they're going to euthanize the dog
i haven't spoken to joe biden about it
then the headline would be
jensaki refuses to deny that joe
that major biden might be euthanized and
then i guess at some point
someone in the past said maybe the
bidens will be getting a cat
and another reporter asking about the
cat if you can imagine
questions we've heard all about dogs we
were promised a white house cat
what what happened to that where is the
cat today's a good day for the cat
i don't have any update on the cat we
know the cat will break the internet
but i don't have any update on its
status so there it is
literally devolving into questions about
dogs and cats and i think part of what's
going on here
part is the reporters don't don't know
what to ask about substantively
part of it is that we are now moving
beyond the reality tv presidency of
donald trump
joe biden isn't tweeting attacks at
people all day long joe biden's
administration
isn't denouncing the press as an
institution and it's sort of like
reporters are struggling
to move beyond the reality show that was
the trump presidency my question to you
is do you
think they don't know what to ask or do
they think that these questions
will be seen as relevant and interesting
by the american people i just don't even
understand the motivation to ask about a
cat
maybe don't ask a question if you have
nothing relevant to ask about maybe
that's part of it where
if you're in the briefing room even if
you have nothing to say
you want to get a question in there and
so you ask about a cat
i really don't have the explanation as
to what's going on but i'd be curious to
hear from you
and we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show
instagram page find us on instagram at
davidpakmanshow
find me on instagram david.pakman
one of our sponsors is sussman and han
sussman and han has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other supplies
to stay safe during covid19 and sussman
and han
is the company that i've personally been
going to
for face masks and other ppe because i
trust the products that they sell and
that's actually why we reached out to
them about becoming a sponsor because
their prices are reasonable ordering is
simple
everything ships within 24 hours and
they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers face shields
sanitizers
sussman and han is also an awesome
company because they've donated over 65
000
masks so far to healthcare institutions
shipping is free on orders over 150
dollars you can go to their website by
going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is right underneath this
video and they'll give you twenty
percent off
when you use the coupon code david